hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons ladies
and gentlemen you were listening to the
Tim Dylan show I have just returned to
California from the sunny Southern
Command said rush limbaugh I used to go
ladies and gentlemen it is open line
Friday from the Palm Beach would say
from sunny South Beach Florida the
southern command center of the EIB
Network it is L rushed both mihashi
he broadcasts in my Palm Beach I was
just in st. Pete Beach Florida
our greatest state the crown jewel of
America why is it so great is it the
sunsets
is it the elder abuse is it that every
other building is a sober house is it
the fact that the rehabilitation is a
major industry I don't know it's all of
those things and more
all of the New York Jews go down to the
East Coast of Florida which is like Palm
Beach Boca that [ __ ] Fort Lauderdale
Miami and then the west coast where I
was which is like Tampa st. Petersburg
Clearwater is the people from Canada and
the Midwest they were telling me that
when I got down there but there are some
people from Long Island New York on the
west coast too but they are so prevalent
on the East Coast that you feel like
you're in New York you feel like you
hear the accents you hear the
complaining you immediately are like oh
I'm home you hear people upset I mean
the first day I got there you the
gravitational pull of Florida is so much
because you when you get there
you spend time there and you go I could
live here I could become this it's
something you become you're not born
that way maybe some people are but you
become a person that just is eating a
conch fritter on the back deck at 3:00
p.m. you know like I went out to lunch
at ocean prime which is a restaurant at
Tampa they have one in Beverly Hills one
in New York it's a chain I got out of
there at 3:00 and my uber driver picked
me up and he goes how was dinner so
that's where they're on because how was
dinner and then he proceeded to tell me
about his wife he was in the asphalt
business his wife defrauded him out of
his company wrote fake checks the whole
thing he's like the DA said it was clear
that she committed a crime because I
didn't charge her I didn't press charges
because we've got two kids he goes her
sister you know said their whole
family's bipolar he goes I just didn't
wanna so he goes now I'm just trying to
get in business with my younger son I'm
like how good ruin his life
you want just your own flesh and blood
he said my younger son wants to go into
business with me so that's what Florida
is like a great place to start over what
a Roger stone say it's a sunny place for
shady people
you know the dirty tricks guy Roger
stone you get the vibe when you're in
Florida that there's a lot of people
there that are running from something
there are people that have given up on
on whatever they tried to do and they've
come down in Florida and they're they're
doing a version of what they wanted to
do and and it there's something nice
about that and there's and everything's
inexpensive relative to New York and LA
and you start thinking like man I could
get in this groove I could really I
stayed at a hotel for one night called
the danse azar which everyone said you
got to stay at the Don
it's where Louis stayed it's on the
beach
beautiful old hotel the owner killed
himself in it again Florida it was a VA
hospital during World War two a lot of
people died there I walk in immediately
there's an old couple complaining that
the restaurant was closed for
renovations
it's 153 a night beautiful Resort 153
and nine right now because I'm between
apartments I am in I don't even know
what I'd call an inn in Burbank yeah
yeah and it's got nothing I mean it is
bare boil it it looked like it looks
industrial like every door looks like
it's a supply closet
this is [ __ ] 2 to 2,200 because if I
wanted to stay West Hollywood it's like
400 500 800 you go down to Florida 150
you get a resort and and that's what I
stayed one extra day the crowds were fun
the people that came out to side
splitters in Tampa you know my cousin
went down to Florida about ten years ago
and she did Florida right my cousin did
Florida right she's addicted to heroin
uh she's in and out of rehabilitations
she also will smoke crack she said to me
she said to me wants into Chili's in
Delray Beach because t me I'm a real
garbage head whatever comes whatever
whatever they bring out i I do not
discriminate
I'll take pills I'll shoot up a smoke
math she's she's a lovely woman but
she's had problems she's had issues
let's not mince words there's been
problems okay I remembered Thanksgiving
a few years ago she was back up from
Florida um she'll come they bring her
back to New York it doesn't work because
New York is like New York it almost
makes me do heroin so if you're on
heroin you don't come back to New York
to like get off heroin so she comes back
she falls in with a bad crowd crew or a
new crew it's amazing when you're doing
those kind of drugs you just figure
who's gonna get those drugs and how are
you gonna get it and she was at
Thanksgiving and my other aunt my aunt
who's like a pill head and a drunk goes
let's do let's go around the table and
say our a thankful for which is always a
waste of everyone's time no one's really
truly thankful for anything because no
one will admit what they're thankful for
no one will admit the reality of what
they say I'm thankful that I got away
with the D way like no one says that no
one will go into the reality of what
they say everybody's like I'm thankful
for the seasons I'm thankful to be
around family and you're not you're not
no one is no one is it's I'm thankful I
didn't get caught cheating on my taxes
I'm thankful my wife didn't catch that
23 roll blowing me in my office
I'm thankful my kid didn't shoot up the
school this year with my parenting he
should have but no one will be on it
that would be great if we all went
around the table and we're like I'm
thankful for this I'm thankful for that
you know I mean half of my family but
thank God I was born white and I could
just be mediocre everything and not of
the cops constantly beating the [ __ ] out
of me even though they should be but so
you you you set up a situation where you
have your everybody when you go around
that table everyone's full of [ __ ] and
my cousin is at the table and she's you
know she's tired you know you know that
means I was an addict for years I don't
talk about her in a judgmental fashion I
get it but she's tired well yeah
tired means that there's there are
problems so we're going around the table
everybody's kind of nervous who's it
gonna get to her I'm trying to think of
something dumb and funny to say I think
I say it I don't know
I forget what I even said I was thankful
for I think I said not now my nanny make
chocolate pudding my nanny makes the
best chocolate pudding it's I think two
packages of mighty fine chocolate one
package of mighty fine vanilla mix it up
you get the pudding skin pudding us to
have skin and and so I said
thank over nanny's pudding or whatever
and everyone laugh so we get to my other
cousin and they're going what are you
thankful for it she's just like picks
her head up and she goes I'm sick and
everyone goes okay and they go right to
the next guy like it what do you
thankful for it and I'm like what do you
see that this wasn't the move but she
went down there and half of Delray Beach
Florida is a rehab the other half of
Delray Beach Florida is a crack house
it's like there's a line down the town
half of them are rehabs half with no
crack houses and you just shimmy over to
the crack houses when you feel like
relapsing and then you go back to the
rehabs and the sober houses and these
sober houses are big business rich kids
that get [ __ ] up their parents pay to
stash them somewhere where they will be
watched and the rehabs kick them out
usually after 28 days so then they can't
come home the parents are like we don't
want to see them that's how we got it
that's why they're doing drugs in the
first place it's because we're busy
making eight million dollars a year at
goldman sachs not raising them so we
clearly don't know what to do with them
put them somewhere and I'll open my
wallet to make that happen the ridge
wallet so what then happens is you have
these sober houses these communities of
people and then my my roommate his girl
was a sober companion her job is to sit
next to rich people on flights so that
they don't order drinks I'm not even
kidding this is an economy right now
poor people can't afford this if you're
broke and I'm gonna talk about my rehab
experience in a minute but if you're
broke you either don't go to rehab or if
you go they kick out as soon as your
insurance is out and they go good
[ __ ] luck go with God go to meetings
go to AAA but if you're rich you go to
all these [ __ ] rehabs which barely
work promises in Malibu
look you're riding a horse you don't
need to do you don't need to take
oxycontin you're on a horse Nicole
Richie you're on a horse now
well then what happens when you're not
on the horse you go well I'm home now
and I'm not on the horse I think I'll
take a pill that's the problem
no one is [ __ ] doing synthetic heroin
because they they they have a lack of
equestrian opportunity that's not it
there's deeper issues you got to get to
but these these fraudulent you know
programs that they have in these you
know billion multi-million dollar
institutions are just to distract you
that's what rich rehab is it's like
distract we have Beach yoga it's Beach
oka
nobody needs to do drugs we're gonna do
yoga at the beach and then we're gonna
talk about our feelings by the sunset
and then we have a five-star chef who's
gonna make You Amit and and you're like
you pampered and it's luxurious and
they're giving you whatever drugs they
can legally give you to get you off the
other drugs and whatever then you go
back and the week the week you're out of
that you're using again you're at one
okay ten ocher fifteen maple whatever
these [ __ ] clubs are on the Sunset
Strip and you got your face full of a
big cake of coke because you learn
nothing you didn't grow spiritually it's
a whole lot of [ __ ] but my cousin had
gone down to a few of these places in
Delray and she's put some clean time
together and then she relapsed and it
said it's a [ __ ] the disease is
insidious it's deadly he doesn't let you
out of its grasp its clutches it's a
lifelong fight and I hundred percent
respect that she's trying it's [ __ ]
hard and I remember I went down there to
perform at a rehab convention because I
usually do a lot of rehab comedy when I
first started comedy those were shows
that I could do I wasn't in at clubs I
wasn't really working on the road so the
idea the road was rehab shows I did one
in Eau Claire Wisconsin where I got one
of the best hackles ever I said
something about you every Dahmer and
somebody in the audience yelled at
Dahmer ate my friend
that was one of the best heckles that I
have ever had
it is the top five ten years of comedy a
lot of people have yelled [ __ ] out that
was a top five um I did a rehab
conversion oh Claire Wisconsin and then
we did one in Pompano Beach Florida flew
into Fort Lauderdale now the guy that
used to book these was a one-armed X
crackhead and Keith uh he had one arm
the arm that he had the fake arm was so
bad it wasn't like it looked like a
Halloween like he got it at a Halloween
store it was like a prosthetic but it
wasn't good it was literally plastic and
it only had one like he couldn't move
any of it it was like an arm that was
always in the position of like him
giving a speech as a coach and he lost
it smoking crack he was a Marine but he
never really saw combat but he used to
get on planes and asked us in first
class because he said he fought for the
country which everyone kind of knew was
a lie like no one believed that and and
that's what's it not the way planes work
you don't get to just sit in first class
because you lost an arm for the country
and also you didn't also you're lying
which I was respected him for I
respected that he would lie like that
and disgrace the idea that there were
people that had lost limbs for the
country who just sat in coach kept their
mouth shut but he lied because you're
always an addict you always even if
you're not doing drugs you're always a
[ __ ] addict those behaviors they
percolate they rise to the surface
they're there they're there and needs to
see it when he would get Maddie but I
can't [ __ ] he turn around me god I can't
[ __ ] I believe this he goes here seats
open in first class he won't let me sit
there and the woman is like that's not
it but you have to buy a first-class
ticket he's like well I'm a veteran I
lost my arm for the country
and then she'd go well thank you for
your service and then to walk by you
know but this is this is his booking the
gigs Keith just plain Keith that's what
he called himself just plain Keith he
had a joke
he used to do other people's jokes there
was this great guy might justify no it
was one of the best comedians and he
died he's an amazing guy he used to do
heroin he had AIDS he was like this
tragic figure but one of the best
comedians I think he won or got glory he
didn't win but he got very close Last
Comic Standing and everybody loved him
he worked the cellar everybody loved my
DeStefano and he did this thing called
Fanny's last ride at the moth which like
makes you cry it's like a great [ __ ]
story he tells him and he used to have
this great joke he would open he'd go
go ahead everybody he'd go after you
know I goes he goes I live I live 10
years clean and everybody would clap and
then he'd go in eight years so that
piece just does that joke and he's like
I do it to honor his memory I'm like
well alright I don't know how that works
but he's like well his brother said I
could do what I'm like I also don't know
if that's how that works
but whatever sit in first class do the
guy's joke what I mean you know your
book and me Who am I at this point and
that's a huge step this other guy Scott
Papa Curie who was this other comic who
like had a big career but then had drug
issues and women issues and all these
problems but we used to travel around
occasionally to gigs and like Woonsocket
Rhode Island and I've talked about it
before on the show we ended up going
down to a convention I forget what it
was it was in Pompano Beach and my
cousin and a few of her friends came to
the show and the show was a disaster I
mean I did really good but it was a
[ __ ] rough cuz it's a convention no
one really sometimes they really love
the comedy this show was like not set up
well nobody was expecting it they sprung
it on everybody it was in a conference
room and I was just fighting for my life
up there but I was doing decently I was
doing okay and then I think the next day
or maybe
was earlier that day me and my cousin
had lunch at Chili's and that's what she
said to me she goes I said what is you
know UK what is it she goes Timmy I love
the family I love everyone I just love
heroin she said very honestly she goes I
just really like doing heroin and it was
just such a moment of honesty and I was
like five thank God I never did heroin
because I bet that's kind of you
probably just get to that point where
you go yet
I like Arawa I'm in the Harrow and it's
like it's such a [ __ ] but what's also
interesting about that whole community
is the people that were drug addicts
then all they all run the rehabs ex-drug
addicts run the rehabs they run the
sober houses you'll be talking to
somebody and they'll be like yeah I'm a
drug counselor said what'd you do last
year they're like home invasions like oh
okay it's been a pretty quick quick
turnaround on that huh you know and then
next year they might be doing home
invasions again you don't know but
they're like in it they're in charge you
know now they're supposed to have a
certain amount of clean time but then
you going off everybody's you know honor
the honor system the I've been clean for
however long you need me to say I've
been clean for it you know so to get a
paycheck and they have a single decay
sack what you're supposed to get
certified and you know helping people
this that and the other thing but it's
it my cousin Ben had a real but few tips
she they let her in for free once they
were like she's been here a bunch will
get a letter one for free I you know and
it's hard because it's tough money
doesn't solve the problem money I mean
money makes it better
it'll help but it doesn't solve the
issue of somebody who has maybe changed
their body chemistry or their physiology
and they are now truly kind of a ticking
time bomb and they're like ready to get
activated and they might put some clean
time behind them six months or a year
and then they just get activated like
that and then they go off the [ __ ]
reservation and then it's like [ __ ] it's
bad I remember when I went right in
beginning a comedy I went to rehab I had
started comedy actually I had started
comedy in late 2010 and I was still
taking pills
I was thinking percocet and things like
that nothing I want to go to rehab to
just get this out of my system it's not
really good and I was I wasn't taking a
lot I was taking like three or four a
day
okay that's still a problem that's the
per now I told like my dad and other
people this they were like you're not
really doing that much I was like well
you know it's this kind of parenting
that is you know why we're here that's
why I'm in this they're like I had no
idea I think you're caught okay you seem
fine you're wearing a suit you got a job
is your job gonna let you take off
they're gonna rehab them like well yeah
but I'm maybe gonna die if I don't so I
should do that right yeah but you're not
taking that much right but it's
progressive I'll take more and more
right I'm drinking I'm doing all these
other things so I go to rehab and when
you go and I went to the place called
the Long Island Center for recovery and
this is out in the Hampton Bays which is
not the nice part of the Hamptons and
the Long Island Center for recovery I
remember as soon as I pulled up I took a
train out there and then I took a cab
and I'm at the Long Island Center for
recovery and I feel like [ __ ] right you
don't you know field you're in rehab you
like my life is becoming man this is no
good bad this is bad so cuz I thought I
was it well if I come out of the closet
and I start to a comedy I'll be able to
just use drugs and drink and it'll all
be fine it'll and that's not the case
you make all those deals you go well if
I'm dishonest I can do drugs honestly
can't we all just do drugs
honestly together like human beings
without these dark secrets let's let's
just we'll we'll be on the other side of
all this I'm living my dream I'm a
comedian it's gonna be good
so what ended up happening I go to
long-on Center for recovery I walk into
the room
this is intake
now intake in a rehab is there they're
basically seeing how [ __ ] up you are
how what they need to do what they have
to do legally what insurance is gonna
pay for that's the big one and then I
put you in a room and they go okay
here's the program blah blah blah so I
show up I sit down and the woman goes
are you drunk
I go no she goes oh you're not drunk huh
I go no I gonna rehab I figured I
wouldn't get drunk the night of it's a
lot better for insurance if you're drunk
I she goes could you go out and get
drunk and then come back I said well
sure I don't really know of any bars she
goes well let's try it first without you
being drunk she goes if you blow if you
take a breathalyzer and you blow like
high blood alcohol level insurance is
like oh we got to pay because the good
insurance people they're not gonna take
your word they like they want you to
prove that you're [ __ ] up so I'm there
my insurance is not good they're not
gonna like let me in this place okay and
I could tell that because you see the
look on her face start to change as the
applications going through and in the
beginning she started to choose using
the word we she's like we're gonna we're
gonna help you out we're a family with
this with that we have to be accountable
we have to do this we have to do that
and then as the insurance was not going
through she changed the weed on you she
was like you're gonna be fine you're
gonna go out you're gonna change
everything you're gonna do what needs to
be done and I'm like we were we were we
a few minutes ago so she finally goes
okay I finagled it I got you eight days
eight days of a 28-day program
you couldn't the good people at my
insurance we're like hey he'll learn it
in a week he'll get better in a week
we're gonna give him a week instead of a
month that's fine for him he'll be fine
so eight days all right baby
you get in you let you have a prison cot
three other dudes one guy was named
Ricky one guy was named Alex there was
another guy I forgot his name but that
guy was telling me that there are no
negative consequences of doing heroin
except that withdrawal and the fact that
it's addictive
he's like heroin is a great drug because
it does nothing negative to your system
except the fact you get addicted to it
and I'm like well I don't know enough to
argue with you but that sounds highly
suspect but you seem very convinced and
then there was a guy who's like
Portuguese who walked around in his
underwear he was an older guy we didn't
know he like muttered to himself and
would laugh occasionally but we didn't
know what his deal was I think he was
drying out I think it was a drunk um I
think so
when you're in rehab you bond with
people incredibly quickly because it's a
prison situation you wake up early in
the morning methods kick down your door
these X method bikers around the rehab
you got to go to an early morning
meeting you gotta go have a shitty
breakfast and you gotta go do dishes
because you're working whatever on the
thing you know and and it's rehab so
they're they're checking you for drugs
checking to see if you smuggled in drugs
they're you know you could pat down to
get random searches you get all that
[ __ ] you know this one girl this fat
girl came in and she she would keep she
would keep packets of honey in the laces
of her shoes and just take the honey out
and just sucked down the honey and then
just interested somehow it had to do it
wasn't just honey like she's somehow
smuggled xanax in to her shoes to sum
out these people are very creative Alex
was a fun kid from Brooke Phil wealthy
part of Long Island part where my
grandfather used to live Alex was like a
bro
Jersey Shore guy had a hot girlfriend
rich mom
he's dead now killed killed himself I
mean I don't know what why he was drugs
was either drugs or he did himself in
but I think it was drugs I think another
one of those dudes is dead too one of
those guys Ricky invited me over his
house a week after we got out of rehab
and I sat down with him and his
girlfriend we watched Jeff Dunham's
special and they loved it
they were like you got to see peanut and
I'm like who's peanut I think Oh peanuts
my favorite one of his puppets and I'm
like well what is it they go he's just
this thing he just his funny thing and
peanuts like a crazy and his girls like
it's like a crazy baby peanuts like a
crazy baby she said and I said okay I
was sitting there watching the Jeff
Dunham with them going is this better
than heroin like is this is this better
than getting a pay-by-the-hour motel and
cutting up cocaine and blasting it til
our mouths and um it can't be right that
kid I don't know if he made it through
either I mean I am these people were all
on Facebook I mean hopefully he's still
alive he was another one of those guys
he got out of rehab but he was still
like in the EDM scene and I was like
pianist is not gonna he's like my
passion is electronic music I'm like you
got to get another passion you got to
switch he said I'm gonna be sober and
it's gonna take my music to the next
line I'm like you got it you can't no
that's like being a drunk and getting
outta rehab me like my passion is bars
I'm never not gonna be in a bar I'm just
gonna be drinking seltzer it's not gonna
happen it was one guy the bar used to
hang out at least his lounge this guy
Mike who I saw the other day just
driving around in in Long Island it was
crazy so him and this other guy George
okay George had like a deformed face he
inherited a bunch of money not a bunch
but he got like 120 grand in a lawsuit
and then some hooker named Carol how
them spend all the money it was crazy
and then he went back to like living in
his car
it's very wild but carol was was kind of
fun but I eat not worth not that much
fun
but so I saw those two just driving
around in a car I'm like I wonder if
they're sober cuz I got Mike was trying
to get sober he came to the bar one day
and he said I'm sobered he was like
drinking water he's like I'm sober I
just love all of you and I'm here so bad
I'm like well this is much worse don't
you see that have a drink
God you here with all of us sober like
you got to change your life when you
sober up you've got a change and that
poor kid that kid Ricky was just like
and then I visited him in jail actually
now I remember that's the memories are
coming back he was in jail and his girls
like Hayes in jail in East Meadow in
Long Island why don't you go visit him
and we I went in and I visited him and I
was okay how's it been and he's like
well you know he's like it's not fun
here and but the thing with rehab is you
you're all brothers in rehab for the
week and then you get out you never see
each other again or it's a funeral or
it's something horrible happened because
it's like their recidivism rate with
that [ __ ] is high it's bad people go
back to go back to go back and uh I
don't know where that other guy is but
there's a lot of people I go back to old
say sometimes I'll think of a kid from
my town of like wonder what happened to
that guy when do what happened to Chico
where's Chico then I'll just look at his
Facebook it's an in memoriam page or
it's not an in memoriam page here's how
you know they don't even make it an in
memoriam page it'll just be like one
[ __ ] who just posts on his page every
day she'll be like you know like I'm
gonna disband shacks in here but that's
not meant to be this is a white girl who
thinks she's Spanish that I'm imitating
it's significantly less funny if she's
actually Spanish she's like she's
probably like mostly white but her name
is like Lisette or something this is
exactly in my head this is where I'm
going with this
like everyday she'll post it as paycheck
it seems to be a lot of people I mean
this is hard cuz I'm Nam do Maresa which
is Yanis Papa's his character but that's
the only Spanish voice I know but so it
will be a [ __ ] who posts on his page
every day she'll be like you know it
seems like a lot of people forgot about
you but I'll never forget about sure a
lot of people forget it's like well yeah
they can't post every day on his page
it's five years later she's like a lot
of people forgot you but I never forget
you and you could tell just one chick
that does this over and over again and
you go oh he's dead like that's how you
know he's dead
cuz it'll be that one chick that keeps
posting I love you I remember when we
used to chill when we used to cheer like
with each other I never forget that time
at the park when I was 14 at you were 30
and you was [ __ ] me on the stairs I
don't know I'm just I'm not saying I'm
just saying that's how you know these
people have passed on it's just one girl
over and over again I love you I always
be remembering you okay move on but it's
difficult I'm glad I'm glad I got out of
that because for a lot of people that's
a lifestyle rehabs a lifestyle it's what
they talk about who they are it's what
they're about they know the good rehabs
are better supposedly after I left the
rehab than the bad like bad people came
into it it wasn't as fun like we were
all trying to get better and then
supposedly right after I left a crop of
people came in that had no interest in
getting sober and a lot of them are just
court-ordered they were just trying to
sneak drugs in and it became an issue
and it became like not a fun spot you
know we were actually trying to not be
you know [ __ ] up that and after I got
out of there I was kind of done I was
really done with drugs mean that was
kind of it I'm trying to think I think
smoke pot a few more times after that
and I was like I just can't do it I put
the [ __ ] panic attacks and then like
[Applause]
so that's what a lot of Florida is
Florida has a lot of people trying to
put it back together and people that
have no interest in putting it together
a lot of pay by the hour motels a lot of
prostitution in Tampa a lot of strip
clubs Florida Project is great [ __ ]
movie I'd like you to see that you
should watch it
[ __ ] phenomenal it's about a place
called the Magic Castle
not this [ __ ] thing in LA where these
clowns jump around these people I'm a
comedian an imagine you shut up I'm just
it's an experience for the audience yeah
okay I got an experience
it's called Steven paddock it's called
the paddock that's what I got for the
audience okay couple of Saudi arms
dealers and a nice patch
I'm kidding shout out Saudi Arabia you
know I love you I'm not I am NOT I am
NOT insinuating that that was an arms
deal gone wrong or that you you know
cooperated with the elements of our
government to do the 9/11 thing or
anything or that you have an underground
alliance with Israel and Britain and us
and you dive hey I don't mean any of
that I'm being a goof I'm being a big
goof I hope that doesn't hurt I hope
you'll bring me over there like fluffy
didn't fluffy over there perform for
like five breathe like five guys with
her beheading people really I think he
did there's like flows like it was like
Muhammad but it was like the the I'm
[ __ ] so exhausted from this plane
right I'm trying to think in their name
the Saudi royal family what was it the
Ben Solomon's I think it's been some
whatever it is the Saudi royal family I
think they brought fluffy over and they
all sat there and Thrones beheading
people and be handing people and he was
like
I like milkshakes I love that that's the
kind of American comedy they like I like
milkshakes is people getting your hands
lobbed off this women being beaten with
sticks outside and then he comes into
the palace and he's like you know I like
to put a cake in a shed and they're like
they're like this is good they're like
this is just good mmm shut out - fluffy
- this is not meant to disparage him
fluff fluff listen you may want to start
I will start doing [ __ ] with you anytime
you want you know hire me I know about
the Hispanic experience in this country
thank you but that's you know are they
talking about before I said Steven
paddock should kill my audience you were
talking about the Magic Castle and yeah
so this thing the Florida produce about
the Magic Castle which is a it's a hotel
it's an extended-stay hotel that people
just live in and it's a great [ __ ]
thing man and they cast his girl from
Instagram briea vanity or whatever who's
like real white trash they didn't even
it was just like they just put the
camera on her and let her go she was
like a great actress but it's like was
she acting and this little girl Brooklyn
Pierce I think was in it this little
girl that was great and I think they
also just used people from the magic
they use people from the hotel and I
think they barely paid them so Hollywood
hooray for Hollywood they're still
living they wouldn't like a movie
they're still living in the magic so but
it's just that culture of and they have
a great ice cream place down there
twisty treat and that's in the florida
project - what if they have something
called a brownie boat which is great
that I I got because it's a it's a Kiev
kids kedo they do sugar free ice cream
sugar brownies and then the next day I
went back to the different one a
different twisty tree and I was it kind
of another brownie boat and this woman's
Haggard woman goes hey she goes we're
privately owned we don't have the
brownie but what do you
mean that's it going into McDonald's you
go I don't we don't we don't do the
double cheeseburger
waha we don't do the McDouble we don't
did a Big Mac here we're privately uh
she goes I don't know what the brownie
boat is nobody can explain him with the
brownie but is I'm like it's the it's
the Banana Boat with brownies so we
don't have that I'm like you know she
said we're on by the same people at own
I forget some other I just complete like
we're all by the same people that don't
Eddie's and she's got her meth head son
and they're helping are like god this is
real Florida [ __ ] did you try to get her
to make it they don't have the right
kind of brownies they're just too shitty
little brownies the bigger fluffier
brownies are at the other one that
twisted she was great there was just uh
I said to the woman what should I get
this is the first twisty treat I was a
quote what should I get and she goes she
goes get get get the brownie boat and
the guy in front of me got the brownie
boat everybody's getting the boat they
like the boat Florida give me the boat
let's not waste our time with the cone
let's not waste our time with the sunt
the Sunday the Sunday
what is this Chicago this is Florida put
it in the boat put it in the trough a
lot of mobile home so I was always near
pervert park that did you ever see
pervert park the documentary no never
watched him pervert Park is a
documentary about a mobile home park in
st. Petersburg Florida which is all
pedophiles and it's like really really
bad like one lady like like abused her
son he's there like abusing
three-year-olds it's very bad but then
there's like one kid that like was 17
he's trying to [ __ ] a 14 year old like
of course it was like the FBI pretending
to be a 14 year old who stay where they
were they were like not busy that day
you know letting terrorists you 9/11 or
letting Boston Marathon thing get bomb
so they were just like well we're sort
of bored today so we're just gonna
pretend to be kids online so this poor
kid I mean obviously he's got problems
too I'm not whatever but he's in there
with like hardened
people and now his life's over and he's
living in this so I was like a cool Ben
I'm like should I do a podcast from
there sounds like what I thought you
were spiraling dude I was so worried
about you called me at like 12:30 in the
morning you're like what if it was me
just yelling about twisty treat in the
pedophile Park just screaming like about
the brownie boom
yeah I go and I go to the next one and
this [ __ ] goes we're privately-owned we
don't have a brownie boat she goes I
don't even know what a brownie boat is I
go it's the Banana Boat with brownies
you dumb [ __ ] there's just a bunch of
pedophiles real smoking cigarettes and
I'm like all right so you guys [ __ ] kids
that's [ __ ] dog but but just
hypothetically if you all de Tracy treat
you'd make the brownie boat right
so I call my from Michael who I love but
he's dumb and he goes yeah you should do
it the documentary is really good it was
good you should do a pot get in a mic
well nobody's if you go in and you're if
you're too nice to them people get mad
at you like if you try to fish here I'm
not a serious journalist so if I try to
do anything that fault feel sympathetic
to them because they aren't my lot of
people don't monstrous thing I mean you
know so if you're too sympathetic to the
people gonna be like you're too
sympathetic and if you're too much of a
dick it doesn't really work I can't go
there and like be a dick to them you
know what I mean I can't be you know so
and then it feels like exploitive or
whatever I mean but it would be probably
an interesting podcast if I went there
and I just talked about twisty tree and
this [ __ ] who [ __ ] me over I was like
yeah you guys you guys you got [ __ ]
when you were young and cuz that's why
they're all there is they got [ __ ] and
they got touched I was like you guys got
a raw deal in life and I get it you have
this horrible thing but I go like I let
them talk for a minute I let a woman go
she's like you know my father [ __ ] me
and it's just a disease and everything I
go yeah
that's bad I go let me ask you a
question now you had a brownie boat she
knows yeah the thing it twisted tree to
go yeah listen to this I go to another
twisty Street this [ __ ] says they don't
have it and they're owned by the same
people own Eddie's what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with it what are the
people who owned Eddie's don't
it's the biggest seller at twisty treat
is the [ __ ] brownie boat the taco
also does well the choco taco that they
definitely make themselves but the point
is the boat is you just see them you see
the pedophiles like you're like I leave
the park and they're like you know what
it's good that we're not out in the
outside world have to deal with people
like that at least we can live in this
little pervert park together mm-hmm
we don't have to deal with people like
that it could be worse
we could have some fat guy from New York
screaming about a brownie boat as soon
as she said we don't have the brownie
butter well I guess I went ha she goes
we don't have ha cuz we're all but the
people who owned Eddie's they go well
what does that have anything to do with
it to be honest I don't even know what
Eddie's is Eddie's was up the blockage
to Eddie's and she said tell me the
whole thing she's like do this was the
first twisty tree time like all the more
reason it should have the [ __ ] boat
she goes well we got bought out by the
guy who owns Eddie's and we're francha
we're allowed to do whatever we want we
don't have the boat I go well don't
people ask for the boat every day she
goes every day people ask for this boat
I go well why don't you [ __ ] why
don't you [ __ ] do it figure it out do
it for the people this whole state is
[ __ ] you got people running around
[ __ ] and sucking for heroin
you got pedophiles in the park you got
Ponzi real estate schemes you got old
people can barely keep the food in their
mouth
you got a 90 degree with it's an Indian
burial ground it's a cursed swamp down
here
all we are asking for is the [ __ ]
brownie pout which is what twisty treat
is known for it's what it is known for
that and the banana bow she goes well I
don't even understand what the brandy
boat is I go I'll say it again
it is the Banana Boat with brownies are
there still bananas I said no but if you
wanted to leave the bananas in that
wouldn't be a problem and then I looked
at her I went also do you know where the
pedophile mobile home park is she goes I
do not I said all right well then just
make the banana boat [ __ ] I'm here on
vacation I want the pedophile park and
the brownie boat it's my vacation hmm
it's a great dock pervert Park it is it
is a difficult it's difficult it's a
difficult doctor watch it's very hard to
watch it's not exactly light it's not
fun it ain't great um but it is
[Music]
instructive in the sense you feel lucky
you feel lucky like I'm lucky I'm not a
pedophile I'm lucky I don't live in
Florida you know I mean this ain't Palm
Beach I'm lucky that I was not [ __ ] as
a kid because I was hot as [ __ ] I
should have been I'm lucky that I get to
use someone else's Netflix password and
I don't even have to pay for this you
feel I mean it's a documentary you just
dude it's a [ __ ] dark I mean it's the
dark [ __ ] life I mean I don't know
what to say you know it's a very tough
we should call that twisty tree
they're closed they're open till 11:00 I
just call her once a day every day hey
it's Tim you recognize my voice yes you
have the boat yet
now we're independent what do you mean
you're independent
every twisty tree is shaped like a big
ice cream cone
there is no independence you're not
doing your own thing it is a big ice
cream cone with a hole in it where a
person pops out it is not you don't put
your own stamp on twisty treat you're
not like what we want to do our lobster
bisque here
no you make the creations that people
have come to depend on you know this is
but yeah it was a good idea that I
didn't do I don't even know how I would
have what I've done walking in the park
with my podcast equipment said hey are
you a pedophile well they all are the
every single one of them everyone in the
park I mean what would I've done I walk
in and go hey is there a hierarchy here
can I get I want like one of the lek
don't want a big one I don't want like
did I knock that out no you're fine
here's the thing with wallets they
matter not all of them not all wallets
matter that's not true
but many people out there you need to
simplify your life you need to pare down
your life you have too much going on you
have too many friends you have too many
family members you have too many you
know nonsensical thoughts and ideas and
opinions you have too many entanglements
you need to pare down you need to
simplify you need to cut these people
out like the cancer they are you need to
take yourself and put yourself in a
different situation you need to simplify
you need to streamline that doesn't only
go for your life but it has a lot to do
with your wallet your accessories your
money the ridge wallet is a very simple
wallet okay it's pretty damn cool it's
metal it slides into your front pocket
no more losing money no more losing
debit or credit cards no more pulling
out a big old leather baseball glove
filled with singles like my father used
to do is while it looked like a big old
baseball glove just a big old beaten
down leather wallet handled by a
beaten-down man the ridge wallet is
sleek it's sexy get in and out pull out
a debit card maybe a business card of a
lawyer you know or doctor only the
essentials the Ridgid wallet is about
essentials which i think many of you are
living your life without you're living
in an era you're you're living with the
idea that abundance has to look like
abundance and it does not abundance in
its truest sense is the absence of
things the absence of things many of you
many of you don't even understand what
I'm talking about right now because
you're not you're not keyed in because
your consciousness level does not match
mine and that is a that is a huge
problem right now but what do I mean
what I say abundance is the absence of
things it is the absence of clutter
abundance is reflected in its truest
form in simplicity having a very bare
simple beautiful home having a very hair
down clean beautiful
living situation same can be said for
your car that's true abundance it's not
having boxes or [ __ ] it's not having
trinkets and toys and gadgets and gizmos
it's not having collectibles and things
stacked up in the garage it's none of
that that's boomer [ __ ] get over that
nobody wants that it's having a few key
possessions but basically living like
you're in a hotel it's airy and light
and clean it's nice
make you populate it with your energy
and your all of that stuff you don't
necessarily need all of the other things
that things or what is putting you in
the grave so that's why the ridge wallet
is so cool because what it basically
does is it allows you to take the first
step in eliminating your friends and
family and living a simpler more
productive life once you get rid of your
wallet and once you learn you can walk
around with a ridge wallet you also
learn that you can walk around with two
friends and not seven losers and you can
have you can talk to one uncle and not
all of them you only need to talk to one
aunt to find out when people died you
don't need to talk to all eight of them
and the ridge wallet is the first step
to that it's the first step to live in a
life of simplicity and isolation away
from these demons from hell that are
trying to drag you into the pits of
their despair away from it away from the
clutter away from the disaster
capitalism away from the toys in the
garbage and the food and the plastic and
the poison away from all the things all
the drugs that you put in your body all
the consumerist materials that you you
you you scatter around yourself to
remind yourself that you alive that
you're alive and that you matter the
ridge wall is the first step to getting
rid of all of that it's the first step
to walking out of that company you don't
care about lighting your house on fire
moving down to the Florida Keys it was
the first few years you live in a tent
people start to trust you okay then
you're working at a small little trinket
store and yeah you're selling a little
coke on the side but it's because you
have to make a goddamn living okay you
burn your passport and you don't pay
taxes anymore and it doesn't matter it's
the first time you felt alive for a long
time
a wife and kids in New Jersey that needs
you that haven't seen you in a while but
it doesn't really matter does it because
when you feel that hot sand on your feet
and that rum and you throw it you feel
like what you always meant to be a
[ __ ] pirate you're a goddamn pirate
okay you living in the Florida Keys now
and you're selling coke and you're
working in a store and it sells a little
lie you know beer koozies and little
stuffed parrots but it doesn't really
matter because you're free and that
freedom you wonder you're like how did
that even happen how did I get the balls
to do that to leave my family
you shouldn't have burned the house down
that was a little [ __ ] up that you did
you kind of you did that that was like
one of those things you just did you
didn't need to do it but you did it that
was a little over the top you know
because now your family is homeless but
they can they can live with they can
live with your wife sister because she
doesn't have a rich wallet that [ __ ]
saves everything including her sister
but you're gonna remember you can
remember or during the ridge wallet you
just say what did I do what made this
massive change in my life you're gonna
go oh I get it I went to Ridge comm
slash Tim T I am I use the code Tim for
10% off my order Ridge comm slash Tim I
used the code Tim for 10% off my order
and then what did I do
I realized that all of my entanglements
were putting me slowly into a grave an
early shallow grave that I didn't want
to be in so I went home I burned my
house down I banded my family and all my
friends I moved to the Florida Keys and
I lived in a tent for two years and sold
cocaine and then I was hired at a small
store I met a woman down there that was
half Cherokee and she lived down there
and she kept running her mouth about the
white man this and the white man that
but she was fine for most of it but you
know those people can't handle the drink
the point is this it's a much better
life the cops eventually found you and
they dragged you back to New Jersey you
had the answer for what they called
arson and it was arson but you had a
lawyer that was pretty good go in and
get you off on an insanity defense you
only had to do six months in a mental
hospital
said you had a complete break okay and
they took that Ridge wallet from you
when you went into the mental
institution because you could
technically kill yourself whether they
thought cuz its metal but as soon as
when they took that Ridge wallet away
from me it was like they're taking the
ring away from Bilbo you remembered you
like [ __ ] I don't have the ridge anymore
when I had the ridge I was in the
Florida Keys with a hot half Cherokee
girlfriend selling cocaine and working
in a store where they sold stuff
Barrett's but now I'm back in a mental
institution because I just pled out on
the fact that I on an arson charge
because I burned my house down two and a
half years ago my wife won't even bring
my kids to see me but you know the first
thing you're gonna do when you get out
of that madhouse you're gonna go get
another [ __ ] Ridge you're gonna get
your Ridge back cuz the ridge isn't dead
they just keep it in a little box and
they gave all your belongings back to
you when you're out you're gonna look at
that Ridge again and you can say we're
too buddy
where's to the next adventure Ridge calm
/ Tim T I am use ridge for 10% off your
order the ridge wallet will take you
places you didn't even know we're
possible so did you go see the Joker
instead of getting the banana boat I saw
Joker in New York okay and it was really
good I enjoyed it I thought it was great
I loved I loved the scene where he's
talking to DeNiro and he shoots the Nira
so I love it's really the only time I've
watched late-night television in the
past three years I was happy with the
outcome where I went yeah makes sense
and it's also so much less dark mm-hmm
then comedy yeah it's like doesn't even
get it it's like not even close to have
breakfast on the road with someone who's
featuring for you it's so much most
people are so bad at comedy that if you
do were to explain to them how bad they
are they would start crying like they
have no idea how bad they're this is the
issue most people are so utterly
hopeless
in comedy that there isn't anything to
he can't tell them to do anything
there is no it would be like if I wanted
to be a marathon runner and other
marathon runners had to take me
seriously and tell me that yeah well you
know yeah a lot of people just you know
start running and you know you get to
get the time's up and you'd have to talk
to me about training you know oh yeah oh
you train you get gotta get in the ice
bath yeah
knowing full well knowing full well that
the chances of me being a successful
marathon runner are equal to the chances
of me flying around the city you know
what I mean like that's worth that so
then you like meet comics on the road
and like these comics were good this
weekend that I that I am that I met this
called Katie was really funny I forgot
her last name Katie Hughes maybe I don't
know she was really funny but then like
it's like but then it's like sometimes
you'll meet comics where it's like
they're so far from where they need to
be there is no you can't tell me you go
Union so bad you're so bad and you're
old and you're not unique and you're
boring and the audience hates you and
you just bomb and there's nothing to do
there's nothing to do except realize
that this is not at all something that
you should pursue professionally
personally in any you should not be on a
stage just because no one can legally
stop you from getting up there does it
mean that you have the right to stand in
front of people and waste their time I
mean that's the reality of so many
comics you meet on the road if she's
very tough they're hack they're not even
half as great the great Kurt Metzger
would say you've got to get good enough
to be hack
right hack means is working with
derivative [ __ ] you're like out there
with nothing it's so bad like some of
these people they'll be like I don't
really know what to do
I'm trying to get some work here and
there I go wow guys what's the points I
mean literally what's the point do you
realize the audience hated you do you
realize that the five minutes you spoke
to them was the worst five minutes of
their day do you realize that were you
there for that were you present are you
present for your own life are you even
casually observing your own life because
if you and I've met people that just
they get on stage they're going to this
they don't even know what they are
anymore
they think it's all going well I'm like
no one laughed they were polite chuckles
pillow it was because it was
uncomfortable people were like huh
uh-huh
they just want you off they want you off
that stage and so quickly back to your
[ __ ] day job they want you so far
away from that it is [ __ ] insane
that you had the nerve to get on a stage
and and put these people through your
delusion and your [ __ ] insanity
that's what it is you're putting someone
else through your insanity right now you
know you're not it ain't gonna happen
you're not meant to be on a stage you're
meant to be in the audience hmm the
majority of people do a comedy now were
just fans of comedy yeah then we're
allowed to get on stage because no one
tells you anymore you suck you're bad no
one tells anyone the truths anymore
honesty is gone from public discourse
it's gone everything's gone any gender
can get their period we're all comedians
my thoughts are just as important is
yours no they're not you dumb [ __ ]
they're not
if they were it would for you it would
be obvious because people would be
laughing that's the goal then they all
talk about their material they're like
you know my material I'm a Terra I feel
like sometimes the room doesn't get I
said the room that gets your material
doesn't exist it is a hospital room the
room for you to perform in is padded
okay straight chai these people need to
be in straight Chuck and I have to sit
there and kindly nod and go yeah you
know you moved to New York I got sir
move to LA whatever you want to do just
get in there and you know keep writing
no no keep not keep keep writing and
sign yourself into a mental institution
don't write another joke shine your name
on an intake paper pull yourself away
[ __ ] lunatics I'm sad it's a world
where no one could be told
honestly that they're their [ __ ] full
of [ __ ] how about how long has this been
we have five minutes like okay hand me
my phone I want to read a quote from the
great Andrew Colin who once got pulled
over and a who once got pulled over jet
skiing and a manatee zone he's a real
Florida man he was speeding in a manatee
zone the great Andrew Colin and he
summed up he summed up Florida really
well he's when I first met him in New
York he's Nikki Glaser's opened her very
funny guy I used to talk about Long
Island he would talk about Florida and
this is how I said we're both gonna end
up in Florida Andrew and he writes back
he goes Medicare fraud Tom Petty horse
[ __ ] two different face eating
stories fake tits nice muscles fried
Gator surfing wakeboarding punching old
people throwing old people down stairs
steal money from a dying old person it
has it all it really does all our best
people Casey Anthony
Terry Schiavo remember that vegetable
that her husband fought the wheel around
team imagine that
what a [ __ ] horseshit world we live
in remember that poor woman wanted to
die he's like no I'll wheel her around
like a vegetable we'll talk about Jesus
for three years
remember that Terry Schiavo that was a
height of Fox News insanity whenever was
that don't let Terry died Terry will be
she'll be kept alive like [ __ ] weekend
at Bernie's she's she's still here I
mean I'm telling you this I have a DNR I
have a DNR I have a DNR where I don't
even have to be near death for them to
let me die I have a DNR if Chelsea
Handler gets another deal at Netflix I'm
not to be resuscitated if Chelsea
Handler gets a deal at Netflix I'm to be
I'm to be taken out and killed
that's my DNR was she will can you
imagine the next IQ and I mean hello
privileges meet Chelsea what's the next
idea she's just walking around the Gaza
Strip sorry about this I didn't realize
as a Jewish person that we actually did
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] sorry about this
this is too real pasta Nicky with no
arms she's like I'm sorry I'm a big
celebrity in America and I realized that
when I did a bunch of jokes calling you
people rats I realized that was not the
move would you like to come you like to
come to my house in Bel Air
while I talk about this Illume privilege
hello Gaza it's me Chelsea if she does
hello Gaza
it's me Chelsea I will like her again
that is what I would like her again if
she has the wherewithal to just walk
around the Gaza Strip and I would be
like this [ __ ] is crazy
she should go to every she should
apologize for everything America's ever
had ever done Tuskegee Airmen hate
Tuskegee
it's me Chelsea
hey I'm Kayla it's me Chelsea I had no
idea that there were people getting
asset without their knowledge I've
always thought I love acid but I know
what I'm taking it
next it's hey MK it's me Chelsea she
just goes and apologizes for everything
that's ever been done great
you know folks you've never been to
Florida
one kid yeah I'm yeah it's a vibe down
there man
it's a [ __ ] vibe there's some other
rooms down there there's a but there's
like off the hook comedy club in Marco
Island I think is like a Red Lobster
with a stage the Miami improv like a big
yeah I'd like to go back there I'd like
to go back to Florida sometime in the
winter not Tampa but another part of it
because it's nice to get out of the cold
even though I'm what do you think that
is he think it's a noise complaint
Benjamin I wonder I bet the funds but I
bet it is hello hi
talking I apologize okay the people at
the coast hotel here are unhappy with
this Benjamin because there's loud
talking so a lot of that the pieces of
[ __ ] in this hotel I should have said
what do they have to sleep for what they
have to sleep for they're just gonna
wake up the next morning and go [ __ ]
chug some nuts this loud talking what if
people wanted to have sex in the room or
watch TV we're not louder than a TV well
I'm probably I'm the TV probably doesn't
work it's probably that's the one reason
well half this place is under
construction to it so it's like I see
the interesting aesthetic here it
couldn't be let it couldn't be more drab
yeah it feels like a double-wide that
they hung curtains in 100% but it's also
like I can't really spend bananas money
on hotels until I'm like I can't I can't
spend my so much would you look at like
the three-day total of hotels or a lot
of money you're like I can't like I
can't do this the amount of money is so
absurd to stay in Los Angeles and New
York - it's like [ __ ] but then you
leave those places and you can like stay
in a palace for no money pretty you know
hmm not everywhere there's some places
like I was looking at rooms in
Indianapolis they were more than I
thought I was a an apples what Omaha
though the rooms looked kind of cheap in
Omaha Omaha I'm gonna call that dude
tomorrow
ask him we're trying to do an epic
podcast in Omaha about the Franklin
scandal where we get some people to talk
maybe haven't talked before anonymously
or whatever we might go and visit Noreen
Gosch who lives in Des Moines a few
hours from Omaha I gotta talk to Nick
Bryan tomorrow Road to Franklin scandal
maybe sometime in November
we'll have to see when yeah but it could
be an interesting it could be very
interesting to get some people to talk
that haven't talked I don't know that
they would but we'll see you know would
it be funny if it got them talked to
like it actually is fake we're like what
you're like the whole thing is we made
it up mean a bunch of kids who made it
up like wait a minute was again a
politician they're gonna ban smoking we
said we just call them all Satanists and
pedophiles like wait a minute none of it
was true they're like not even a little
like wait what that's crazy I mean I
think that I think that could be an epic
and spooky podcast
it'd be like spooky and you you know you
would do it and you'd be like yeah you
know be in a room like this somebody
would come in they would say something
horrific and heinous like really really
[ __ ] up you know what I mean like they
would it would they would tell you
something it was done to them or you'd
be like this is [ __ ] up
and I would look at them and I have
you've been a twisty tree because I went
and then I had the banana that brownie
vote and then the next day I go and they
those [ __ ] like we're
independently-owned we're all by the
same people that own a tease and I'm
like what does that have to do with the
price of tea in China
oh wait hold I keep calling ya round
case you would chain in the radiator me
and beaten the whole point of a
franchise is to have a few items that
are consistent goodbye
good night and good luck hardly
Weinstein showed up to a comedy show in
New York City over the last few days I
think it was last night of two nights
ago
this actors group look at maybe a
networking group of actors in New York
had an event and the woman who owned the
or ran the group thought it would be a
good idea to invite harf I mean who
better than to tell these actors what
they need to do who better to offer
advice and counsel who better than to
Shepherd the careers of young vulnerable
impressionable actors then the legend
himself Harvey Weinstein
seems like a good idea doesn't it does
it seem like a good idea that um it's
amazing that no one vetoed that that
nobody said you know I gotta be honest I
know he's made some good movies but I
don't think it's the best idea to have
him sit in the audience at a comedy show
during this actors event it may seem in
bad taste if we have a man that's been
accused by 87 women of rape many of them
were actors it might be in bad taste to
have him sit in the front row of the
show with his big grin and he was called
out by this comedian I figure name was
Kelly Bachmann and she got maybe 75 80
thousand Twitter followers overnight and
I believe her clip is where is it
Benjamin it's up at five million
something like that I'm going to
right now she had about 5 million views
on the clip of her calling out Harvey
Weinstein 4.8 mil for point 8 million on
the clip how many followers she got
seventy seven point three seventy seven
point three go follow me on Twitter
folks Tim Jay Dylan because you know I
respect her I told people to follow her
but like now it's getting out of hand
quite quickly
you know what would I have done you know
she called out Harvey talked about her
own experience go watch the clip it's a
funny clip I respect that a lot of
comics didn't say anything cuz comics
are [ __ ] and you know they were
probably still thinking they're like you
know Harvey's probably coming back
Harvey will be back I don't want to run
my mouth what would I have done great
question I racked my brain let's be
honest Harvey would probably enjoy my
act now because my act is prorate
because he's a human being with blood in
his veins and those people like what I
do they enjoy what I do I'm good at it
Harvey would have laughed what if I had
seen that what if I had been crushing
with Harv what have Harvey been laughing
belly laughing so hard what if you'd
whispered to somebody at his table this
guy's a [ __ ] genius what if I saw him
out of the words this guy is a [ __ ]
genius
I wish I still had the power to make him
a star what if I heard that what if I
saw that would I've taken my time to
berate him from the stage what if I was
really slaying slaying the room and
nobody laughing harder than Harvey
Weinstein nobody imagined maybe three
years ago
Harvey Weinstein showing up to a show
and you're just killing say hey Harv
cuz when did this break this didn't
break this is this is I think the
Weinstein news broke in 2017 2018 but
it's not that long ago yeah I think like
a month before Louie
right I don't
I mean so if you went back a few years
ago which is not that long and Harvey
Weinstein was in the audience at a
comedy show you'd be like whoa tonight's
the night tonight's my night and it was
still her night this was still a big
night for her here's here's what you
want to know what we really draw from
this event
Harvey is still making [ __ ] stars he
is still making stars and don't think he
doesn't know it don't think he doesn't
know it he just launched of a woman open
mic girl maybe maybe not maybe she was
doing some other shows I don't know I
don't see her out on the road I don't
know what else she's doing maybe she's a
writer I'm not trying to denigrate her
she's probably she's probably very funny
she was she she handled that situation
very well
it's very adapt she was good to the
things she said were very funny but she
was obscure and Harvey made her a star
maybe the last woman she might even say
in an interview on the last woman Harvey
wants he made a star right
very interesting folks isn't it fun of
the world works
it's wild that's just how my mind works
because I say Harvey's still out there
making stars just being in the same room
with Harvey wants to him change your
life and it did overnight you know
what would I have done it's a great
question it's a great question would
I've
recognized them probably when I got on
stage I saw Harvey Weinstein there I
would have definitely addressed him and
I would not have been deferential to
Harvey Weinstein I would have tried to
be very funny though but I would have
called him a rapist I mean I say the
Ellen's in the CIA I say wild things
that are true but I I have no problem
talking [ __ ] but I think it's good that
it came from a woman and a rape survivor
I believe that I think that was more
than move you know I might have went the
angles like God Harvey Weinstein I bad
your life now you're the [ __ ] comedy
show what a bunch of nobodies shouldn't
raped all those people huh you know so I
think I think it was probably best well
it's amazing as it were dudes in the
back oh and sugar when she referenced it
who the [ __ ] a day sure you know if she
really think had a Gatsby has a point
maybe Nanette maybe she's right yo sure
don't say nothing about Harvey what kind
of goons this is a guy that had the
Mossad X Mossad agents on his payroll
intimidating women you know and they
can't get him on anything huh nobody
could get him and can't put him in jail
got all these people can't get him on
anything you heard those tapes the tapes
are kind of horrific where you know he's
just trying to get into this woman's
room it's just like no no no come and
easy let me in let me in you know he got
off on torturing and terrorizing people
I mean that's clear you know no matter
what you think about you know no matter
what you think about you know due
process and whatever and all your you
know people cuz that's his defense you
know well it's the court of public
opinion and say yeah but the
preponderance of evidence is high
there's a lot including your own words
and actions knock
um lose gum has tweeted something funny
he goes harvey weinstein in the audience
is gang fest of course not he would have
been in the green room very funny
every now and then lewis is very very
funny it's not often but every now and
then he's very fun Ben you got to shut
those dogs out okay I I mean this is
yeah you live in a neighborhood I mean
Ben has two useless dogs and they'll be
useless children eventually but him and
his chick I have these two dogs and dogs
are they practice on like you practice
on dogs and I look at some people with
dogs that can't behave and I'll make man
their kids are gonna suck their kids are
gonna be disrespectful and I gotta be
honest with you it's not a good omen
that these dogs are just poorly behaved
and you know and I mean you realize that
this is like you're gonna have you and
her or whatever the hell you're doing
you're gonna have to get better when you
have children because dogs are this is
like a rehearsal for children and if
these dogs were children they would be
like running around you know going crazy
yeah so I mean I look at people's dogs
and I go oh well you're gonna have
children and then these children are
gonna be a problem you know so hopefully
you two figure it out between now and
then it's [ __ ] kids threw up my train
of thought you know Lois can be very
very funny and chooses a lot of times
just you know fight get in fights and
troll people but he can actually be very
funny that's I think people I don't
think people realize but I was trying to
do we're trying to go down to Omaha
Nebraska and do an episode of the show
about the Franklin scandal and he's not
gonna happen for a million reasons
because I'm not a journalist and I don't
have the resources and then the people
that are journalists uh
you know people are very protective of
their own stories and their own scoops
and they want to quote unquote own that
info even though it's somewhat public
record so this whole idea of like when
people tell me they like oh you should
do more conspiracy stuff on the show you
should do more you know deep dives and
investigations and stuff it's kind of
like well I don't that's not my job I'm
a comedian what I will do is I will
showcase the work of other people I find
credible but they have to be kind of
willing to do that they have to be and
if they have other projects that they
feel like will be jeopardized if they do
that I completely understand them not
wanting to do it they've put their lives
a lot of people with this conspiracy
it's not just a Franklin scandal it's a
lot of different things people dedicate
their lives to this [ __ ] and they want
to get a payday they want to expose
people they want it but they also want
to make a little money because they put
themselves at a professional and
personal risk to do the reporting that
they've done and now they want a payday
you know so they come to LA and
Hollywood and they get all these holding
deals are we gonna make a movie and
that's tonight and you know they these
people they blow smoke up your ass and
tell you everything's gonna be great no
you're gonna do this and that's gonna be
worldwide phenomenon and you're gonna be
the guy that broke the thing and the
movie is gonna make everybody care
because by the way that's really
American the goal now is never
congressional investigation or anything
it's a movie the goal is the only way to
get the American public to care about
anything is to have like a like a movie
or a Netflix series that gets a lot of
attention like that would be it that you
know if you wanted to wake people up
about anything you'd have to like put it
in a Marvel film you'd have to sneak it
into a Marvel film to get people
interested in it I mean so I think a lot
of people in the in the conspiracy space
imagined that eventually they're gonna
get a documentary user and then those
documentaries are gonna be features and
then those features gonna wake people up
and then because JFK did it to an extent
you know JFK people started getting
interested in that there was then
pressure and they released some records
again what did that all add up to you
tell me but it certainly it certainly
opened the window open the door to more
of a legitimate inquiry into that event
so that could happen and I think that
can happen usually what happens is it's
usually 50 years after the event
happened when everybody's dead that
people start figuring out what happened
or that there's even like some idea of
you know JFK was assassinated I think in
1963 and JFK the movie came out in the
90s which is about 30 years later I
think in the 90s
Jeff cake came out okay get JFK up and
[Applause]
it was a good movie 1991 yes a 91 about
30 years later you know maybe there will
be a movie made about the Franklin
scandal there'll be a movie made sooner
about Jeffrey Epstein because he's dead
so boom you can you can you know that'll
come out next year they'll do a Jeffrey
Epstein movie it'll be a year or two
from now maybe not even it'll be a movie
about a guy with a secret island and all
these rich and powerful people but it
won't hint to you you'll never get
really close to what was going on and I
don't believe they'll you know portray
any real politicians in it and one
wonders if they'll even suggest that
these people are at the top of the
political you know system in their
countries it might just be guys in suits
walking around an island that you know
are rich and powerful but like are they
going to or it would the movie be like
this guy's the leader of a country
because that that I think would change
you know if they did a movie and they
wanted to make it an accurate depiction
you would have to have leaders of
countries going to this island I think
they'll actually just have you know
people that have nice watches on and
will have to you know deduct the dare of
rich powerful but it's not gonna be like
you know it's not gonna be a direct you
know and we'll see I could be wrong
so the problem
we do in the Franklin scandal episode in
Omaha is because I don't have I'm not
getting anyone to talk nobody's gonna
talk to me I you know nobody's good
people to Google me this year I've
dressed up like Megan McCain I also
don't know how to judge the veracity of
what other people are saying I don't I
mean I can't cross check things this is
not my job
there's no what I do I have great
respect for the people who do it but
those people need to need to facilitate
this and you know maybe they will in the
future and will do in the future but I
think when people are like you should do
more you're selling out course or you
won't do two good spirits like number
one conspiracies are mainstream dummies
they're trying to make movies about all
this [ __ ] people are so dumb you guys
are all so [ __ ] behind you know and
you know you can't even grasp that the
[ __ ] can you bring the man please you
know people like all this baggage around
it's like an excuse you know the dog we
have the dog take the love that you give
to the dogs and give it to something
that's gonna matter like a business like
children enough with the [ __ ] animals
don't edit this part out enough with the
[ __ ] animals folks it's it's sick
it's really sick it's like instead of
getting the going to a doctor and
figuring out why you're so [ __ ] up in
the head you just hug this warm ball of
fur enough with this folks get a clue
get a handle on your [ __ ] life okay
enough these animals don't even want to
[ __ ] live what you have for them half
of them are bred there they're dr.
Moreau animals that they crossbreed then
they make these little freak things that
don't even know why they're alive they
can barely breathe half these things and
they just sit on a pillow with you and
watch your water post mates it's not
what they want they don't even know why
they're on the [ __ ] planet you know
and it's every loser has nine dogs and
can't do anything because of the dogs
that's every loser story I kill my
daughter's needs me I can't go and do
anything in the world my doggy needs me
your dog doesn't even even want to be
near you your dog doesn't even know why
it's living in your basement so get rid
of the [ __ ] animals until you have an
actual
life where you can have bring other
living things into your life and take
care of them okay it's it's a disgusting
fetish that I'm sick of I'm truly sick
of these dirty people with their filthy
homes and the disgusting dogs my friend
just got a dog he's a good soul so nice
over dog I'm not drinking going out do
blow because whoo I have a dog now what
what you stop doing drugs because you
got a dog well there's a problem fix the
problem I'm sure the dog loves that
being the only thing that stands between
you and a coke man it's really so what I
was saying about the conspiracy stuff is
that it gets a lot tougher when there's
egos involved all of these guys have you
guys
everybody's written a book has an ego
everybody's been part of a documentary
doesn't you go everybody wants to have
on their turf they want to own the story
they want it to be done a certain way
then they they get financial backers to
make these things into movies or a
bigger documentaries and then those
people want exclusivity and it's a whole
thing so it's actually a lot tougher
than you would imagine
you know the smiley face killers for
example this is just an example I want
to tell you people this cuz many not all
of my fans but some of some of my
friends are literally literal they're
they're brain dead like they have they
don't have blood or oxygen running to
their brain and they're somehow alive
it's a medical miracle it's a literal
medical miracle some of the people the
message may I wanted to do follow-up on
the smiley face killers episode if you
don't recall that it's really
interesting one join the patreon check
it out smiley face killers was
supposedly this gang of serial killers
traveling around the country or they
have cells in different cities and
they're killing young good-looking
college-educated males and throwing them
in a river this is what was alleged
there was a show on it that oxygen
networked in it was a bad show it
diminished the credibility of what I
tried to do pretty pretty severely to be
honest because it was shot like a
reality show and but again it's just you
know everybody's got their hand out and
these people just want to yeah yeah
we're gonna put you on TV that's totally
fine I understand that I totally get it
I know that TV has an allure new media
whatever I had a guy that felt like that
claim to be a victim a potential victim
this mother
I found them credible I believed them it
was completely happenstance that I ran
into him in Wisconsin which is a hotbed
of this activity his story would checked
out and it was very interesting and I
had him on the show is one of our most
successful episodes so I email these
three goofballs that have been touting
this theory for 20 years okay one of
them is this guy I forget his name he's
been accused of sexual assault there's
another one I think he went and lied to
some college campus and he was okay you
know anything about this uh smiley face
killer why don't you put your smiley
face on my god they took his dick out
there's this guy Kevin Gannon right is
that his name Kevin Gannon yeah he likes
to take his [ __ ] out in the middle of
the investigation tank so that that
goofball and then this other guy Leigh
Gilbertson who's just some professor at
st. cloud you by the way these three
losers are probably killing these kids
to get a show on oxygen Network and then
some other Italian goon from Long Island
or Jersey or my neck of the woods some
who's um I'm sure is a nice guy you know
a cop used to listen to shove my friend
Michelle and she said they were these
were like nice guys but they were kind
of whatever like you know you know yeah
they were just you know she's like yeah
they're you know they're they're uh
they're real New York guys they got
everybody's got a million stories and
you know what's true and what's not and
they got a million ideas and opinions
but you know they're probably not the
most careful people that have ever lived
and now by the way I totally believe
something's wrong with the smiley face
killer like I believe something's going
on with the drownings and stuff I
believe that there's there's certainly
something that's going on 100% a lot of
these make
it's in the dead of winter these kids
end up two miles from the bar the party
that they were in nobody and people are
going well people drunk they like to be
by the water it's like yeah in July not
in February nobody is walking two miles
in February by the icy River to get home
I mean it's just not rational right so I
don't discredit this theory but the
people that came up with it you know
these are you know people who they don't
read the most credible okay you know
they do this reality short oxygen which
I get it they want to get the you know
they want to get their story out there
you know the overweight housewives you
know so they could talk about it while
they had Weight Watchers meetings I saw
something there on oxygen about young
boys getting killed how many points does
the bathtub of lasagna have is that how
many points is that a tub of lasagna
like a bathtub portion so I emailed Lea
Gilbertson this one of these guys who
helped originate this theory who works
at like st. Cloud Minnesota whatever I
email him I go hi my name is Tim Dylan
I'm a comedian I did a hugely popular
episode on the show I'd reached out to
you before you had told me that you were
waiting to see what oxygen network was
gonna do and if they were gonna renew
you and then you know obviously there's
you know they might have a say in what
press you do but I was following up with
you because I didn't see you on the
schedule for next season of oxygen which
I'd they're probably not you know
because she can't beat this thing
forever you know these people be doing
it for 20 years I've been dragging these
parents along for 20 years and there's
been no convictions no nothing no
arrests they've got a few cases
reclassified as homicides or maybe one
case one case which I think is good so
email I'll read you this guy's email
back to me so I just want to show you
this
the reality of what you're dealing with
here I'll read it back to you guys right
now word for word I read you my email
and then his email and you can see you
know where it is
I was like hey hey just circling back
with you leave my podcast episode on the
smiley face killers was very well
received we got somewhere between 150
and 200 thousand downloads on the
episode I had reached out earlier about
a potential interview I know that you
guys were waiting to hear back from
oxygen just circling back to see if you
have any more information about
potentially another season and if you
would be available to do an episode of
the show okay he comes back to me
because Tim thank you for the invite and
offer to present the story of the young
man to a border audience not broader
border audio again I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna [ __ ] on him for a [ __ ] typos
you know but sometimes a type old just
give you a little bit of an idea we have
discussed this amongst our team the team
the team given the gravity of this topic
a comedy venue slash genre does not seem
appropriate were you to have another
outlet then we could perhaps accommodate
your request again thanks for extending
the opportunity again so I've not
responded I think I'm gonna respond and
go ahead we cover a lot of serious
topics on the show we handled them
responsibly I've had xci agents on the
show I've had best-selling authors on
the show and I've had people that have
said that my interviews the interviews
that me and Ray did with them were
better than interviews that they that
were done with them at ABC or CBS or NBC
Mark Kelly Adi said that he wrote the
book lavoro the inside story in the
Russian mafia he was like these two
comedians did a great job interviewing
me I don't think that'll change his
opinion by the way of whether he wants
to come on I'll fill him in on those
indisputable facts I don't think that'll
change his opinion because these people
are waiting for I'm telling you they're
all waiting for the movie deal
telling you they're all waiting for the
next season in the TV show so don't come
to me and go you know conspiracies to
yourself listen buddy there's layers to
this [ __ ] that you [ __ ] don't know
about cuz you're sitting on your couch
[ __ ] and you have no clue and you
don't know any of these people you don't
talk to any of them these people all
want a payday it's completely rational
I'm not hating on them why would they do
this if there was no benefit okay there
needs to be some benefit do they also
want to help people and get justice yeah
sure of course they do
they wouldn't have spent years on this
without that being a thing but they also
want this to be seen by the broadest
audience possible so they're not
necessarily convinced that I can deliver
that to them or they're not convinced
that they don't want to muck up their
ability to down the line get a bigger
deal somewhere from some outlet that is
going to provide them with one so that
is a problem that you run into often
with a lot of these people not all of
them but a lot of them especially when
there's something salacious smileyface
kills could be a great [ __ ] movie I'd
go see it you know that's the problem
here you know like Edward Snowden was on
rogue and poor guys living in Moscow
he's on a run what would I have done if
I had worse Snowden I probably would
have just went to Chili's to be honest
because I don't truly have faith in the
people of the country they don't care
that they're being surveilled we've
talked about it before I I talked to
people they're like so what am i doing I
don't care to deal watching me you could
watch me eat pizzas or the food who
cares
call my ex-girlfriend ahora
they don't understand that having
everything you've ever said or done
being stored in a bank waiting to be
weaponized against you by tyrannical
governments not the thing you didn't get
it good for you at Snowden some people
probably get it
hopefully changes history it's certainly
you're a historical figure and you got a
lot more faith than these [ __ ] and I
do I would have went to Chili's I would
have brought five of my friends to a
Chili's from Long Island and sat them
down and explained to everything that I
had found and saw and I would have
looked at them and I would have
explained that I'm like guys everything
guys I was sat him down I would look at
my friend Ryan I see Ryan every single
thing you've ever typed into a Google
search bar everything you've said on the
phone everything you've texted to
somebody everything you've looked up
it's all being saved in a database and
the government gets to just do whatever
they want with it I tell all my friends
you know you know what their response
would be the big yo I ordered the burger
medium-rare it's not rare it's [ __ ]
it's like brown it's like a [ __ ]
piece of meat on the [ __ ] floor I
paid money for this what the [ __ ] yo
these egg rolls are good too
southwestern egg rolls and then I would
have said to myself wow so if I go
forward with this information I'm gonna
be put in jail and I'll have to probably
live in Moscow
I just want to silently ate the egg roll
look at all my friends went home and
went to bed went you know what what are
we saving what are we really truly
saving I'm not against Nodin doing it
I'm just thinking about my own you know
going back to Harvey Weinstein yeah I
would have said something to him but
what if what if Harvey just got it what
if he laughed at all the new stuff
what have you laughed at all my new
material
what if he pulled me aside after the
show and said listen I got an idea for
you sure
it's easy to say that I would be
repulsed by him and I would because he's
a rapist but man I've done a lot of
rooms where good people just didn't get
it they stared at you
what if Harvey was howling cackling
hitting the table hooting and hollering
connecting with my material in a way
that maybe nobody ever had a way that
made it all worth it the shitty planes
and the shitty clubs and the shitty
hotels and the bar shows and the lack of
friends and family and the loneliness
what if I looked at him and he got it he
understood what I was doing up there we
were on the same [ __ ] frequency what
would I have done when I like Edward
Snowden I've blown the whistle or would
I've eaten the southwestern egg roll I
don't know and I never will